and the Bitcoin movement is Satoshi gave  us ethical money nobody controls it you  have to pay for it by burning energy or  by buying it with real cash and you  can't corrupt it you can't issue more  it's capped at 21 million nobody gets to  you know co-opt it or use it in a  useless fashion to make themselves Rich  okay that's Bitcoin  um the crypto world is you know well we  invented Solana to be better than  Bitcoin and we invented such and such  ftt to be cleaner than Bitcoin and don't  mind the fact that we gave 80 percent of  it to ourself right and that uh and that  we're going to dump the rest of the  general public and we're opaque about it  now that that uh war is going on on  Capitol Hill where the crypto Lobby is  lobbying for light or no regulation let  us basically issue these tokens and make  them Commodities and so we don't have  any Securities laws constraining us